[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory in
2016 we finally got fantastic be
somewhere to find them the first
installment of an alleged five-part film
series introducing us to a new wisting
world one so similar yet so different it
highlighted what the wisting world was
like in a different era in different
parts of the world and placed an
emphasis on all sorts of new and neverbe
seen characters creatures and places we
saw the Wizarding World in America for
the first time creatures like nifflers
new magic new protagonists and even a
new antagonist the first film was an
entirely new magical experience showing
us so many unfamiliar things in a world
that had become otherwise so familiar
and just 2 years later in 2018 the
follow-up film came Fantastic Beasts the
crimes of grindewald crimes of grindal
was able to continue on the path that
the first film had laid introducing us
to so many new Concepts and ideas
however they were also able to
interweave aspects of the magical world
that we were already familiar with
aspects from the original Harry Potter
films this was a good strategy to try
and reel in and Captivate audiences that
were heavy-hearted of the veritable lack
of old Harry Potter content the content
that we had grown up with
but this is also where things started to
hit the fan despite the very best
efforts of Warner Bros each of the
Fantastic Beast films released thus far
had come under heavy scrutiny from their
magical fan base mainly being criticized
for a plot that seemed a little all over
the place however the negative attention
was duly noted prompting big changes for
the three films still to come in the
franchise negative reviews and weak box
office receipts of the whole series was
something which Warner Bros noticed
quite s suddenly raising serious
concerns about their plans to launch
Five series of spin-offs Warner Bros has
now shown a great deal of confidence in
giving the third series with a great
deal of effort not to replicate the fate
of previous films the negative attention
forced filmmakers to re-evaluate their
strategy and actually pushed the film's
release date back so that they could
take extra time to rewrite the
screenplay they even Enlisted the help
of Harry Potter alumnist Steve cloves
who was an integral part of the Harry
Potter film
things were looking good and in 2022 a
whopping 4 years after the release of
the part one we finally got part three
Fantastic Beasts the secrets of
Dumbledore but unfortunately this one
suffered the same fate as the first two
putting Warner Brothers in the
uncomfortable position of putting a halt
to production on the follow-up films at
least it very much looks that way
fortunately for casuals three did
complete the story in a way Dumbledore
and N man managed to defeat sort of
grindlewald the real Chillin selected a
new supreme mugwump n and Tina reconcile
and Jacob proposes to Queenie but for
those with a deeper understanding of
Harry Potter law they'll know that there
is still a lot missing and the very
first hint that were missing some things
is in the very first installment of the
Harry Potter series when Harry views a
chocolate frog card with Dumbledore's
name on it alas Dumbledore currently
Headmaster of Hogwarts considered by
many the greatest wizard of modern times
Dumbledore is particularly famous for
his defeat of the dark wizard
grindlewald in
1945 and there it is famous defeat of
dark wizard grindal in
1945 secrets of Dumbledore ends in 1932
which leaves a whopping 13 years
entirely unaccounted for because a new
Fantastic Beast film seems improbable at
this point today I'm going to be filling
in the blanks taking a look at those 13
long years is we may never get a chance
to see on screen I can only operate
within the existing law so there's
certainly still going to be some missing
information but bear with me quick
summary before we dive into what happens
after part three let me first just
provide a very brief recap of what has
happened so far fantastic Beast 1 came
out nearly 8 years ago at this stage so
I believe a refresher is in order
fantastic Beast one fantastic beast and
where to find them takes place in the
year
1926 the film follows the adventures of
NES Commander a wizard and magical
creature Enthusiast from England as he
arrives in New York City he carries a
mysterious suitcase filled with various
magical creatures upon his arrival n's
suitcase gets accidentally swapped with
that of Jacob Kowalski a nomad factory
worker some of the magical creatures
escape and N Endeavors to recapture them
with the help of Jacob their actions
catch the attention of Tina Goldstein a
former Aura who's been demoted to a IAL
position in the magical Congress of the
United States of America makusa n
eventually discovers a young obscurial
named Credence barebone who is under the
abusive care of his adopted mother Mary
Lou an obscurus is a dangerous and dark
parasitic Force formed by the
suppression of magical abilities and for
reasons that are later explained persal
Graves a high-ranking aura at makusa is
particularly interested in young
Credence as new Endeavors to find the
escaped creatures he discovers that
there are dark Forces at play with
Tina's help he discovers that grindal
has been disguised as persal Graves and
that he was interested in harnessing the
power of the obscurial Credence barebone
the film concludes with new Tina Jacob
and Queenie Tina's sister successfully
apprehending grindal and preventing the
obscurus from causing further
destruction in the end Jacob's memories
of the magical world are erased due to
makusa regulations and n departs for
Europe Fantastic Beasts 2 Fantastic
Beasts the crimes of grindal takes place
in the year 1927 shortly after the
events of the first film The Story
follows n's Commander as he is enlisted
by Alber Dumbledore to help thwart the
plans of the dark wizard gallet
grindlewald grindewald escapes from
makusa and sets out to gather followers
who share his belief in Wizarding
Supremacy n is initially reluctant to
get involved but is convinced by
Dumbledore's request to find greed
bebone who is believed to be the key to
stopping grinder wald's reign of terror
meanwhile in Paris new encounters his
former love interest Lita L strange who
is now engaged to his brother Theus
Lita's complex passed intertwines with
the search for Credence as grindal gains
power tensions rise within the Wizarding
Community n along with Tina Jacob and
Queeny join forces to find Credence
before grindal does they discover that
Credence is on a quest asked for his
true identity seeking answers along the
way in the climactic battle grindal
convinces Credence to join his cause by
promising information about his past
Queeny aligns herself with grindewald
driven by her desire for freedom to
marry Jacob who she believes cannot
legally wed her due to Wizarding laws
the film ends with grindelwald's rally
where he Reveals His true intentions for
a Wizarding Revolution setting the stage
for the upcoming conflict between him
and the resistance LED by new and his
allies before the credits rooll
grindewald reveals to Credence that he
is actually a member of The Dumbledore
family and that his real name is aurelus
Dumbledore fantastic Beast 3 fantastic
Beast 3 The Secret of Dumbledore takes
place in the year
1932 the film starts with Alber
Dumbledore and G grindewald briefly
meeting in a muggle tea shop and
acknowledging their mutual feelings
grindal then Reveals His plan to destroy
the Muggle World which Dumbledore
denounces as Madness
explaining that he once supported this
ideology in his youth but has since
changed meanwhile in Quin China NES
Commander helps a Chillin give birth but
greenwald's followers attack killing the
mother and kidnapping one of the
newborns grindewald intends to harness
the baby's precognitive Powers however n
saves the other twin Chillin unable to
directly challenge grald due to a blood
pact Dumbledore recruits new his brother
Theus L Hicks Usef
Jacob Kowalski and Bunty to stop grind's
plan they traveled to Berlin where they
plant Yousef as a spy in grindelwald's
Inner Circle grindal convinces the
international Confederation of wizards
to clear him of charges and allows him
to run for Supreme mugwump of the
icw grindelwald's acolytes arrest Theus
and plan to assassinate a Brazilian
candidate new goes to the kkstar prison
to free thesis Jacob and L Escape but a
framed for attempting to kill grindewald
greence who battles Dumbledore realizes
he's abor's illegitimate son and
questions his loyalty to grindewald
later leaders from The Whiting World
Gather in Bhutan for the Walk of the
Chillin ritual grindewald uses
necromancy to reanimate the dead Chillin
and manipulates it to choose him as the
new supreme leader the team arrives and
confronts grindelwald's followers Queeny
renounces grindal and his cor Jacob the
surviving Chillin is Feld bowing to
Dumbledore and a chosen alternative
supreme leader vencia Santos enraged
grindal tries to kill Credence but ABA
for and Dumbledore protect him their
clashing spells break the blood paact
and grindlewald escapes ABA forth
accepts Credence as his son and Jacob
and Queeny Mary Dumbledore Thanks new
before disappearing into the night and
on that note we should be just about up
to date what next well while secrets of
Dumbledore did wrap up the immediate
plot there was still a lot of unanswered
questions at the end of the last film
questions like what was the fate of the
newly introduced Dumbledore family
member orias Dumbledore SL Creedence
barbone and who is his mother what's
going on with Tina and new what really
happened with Ariana Dumbledore how did
she die what happened to Nini after
crimes of grindlewald and finally what
happened to grindlewald
while I won't be able to get as granular
as I might like due to obvious
limitations on published law here are
some long- awaited answers to these
unanswered questions Credence after the
events of the Walk of the Chillin ritual
Credence is in immense pain and we
witness his father abber forth carrying
him down a set of stairs he looks to be
in particularly rough shape however he
also accepts his father's invitation to
go home with him to hogsma and aelius
who now recognizes himself by his birth
name is taken back to Scotland and Abba
for's home at the Hogs Head Inn through
a port key from Bhutan the implication
here is that Abu for is going to try and
nurture his son back to Good Health
however although orelus survives grind
wald's attempts to kill him his
obscurial nature continues to poison him
which leads us to believe that he has
little time remaining from there things
are left a little ambiguous but there
are a couple of clues that provide
insight into what happens to the newly
recognized Dumbledore in his weaken
State we witnessed credence's phoenix
flying off into the distance and in case
you've forgotten something very similar
happens to Dumbledore after his death in
Half Blood Prince as he lay there he
became aware suddenly that the grounds
were silent Forks had stopped singing
and he knew without knowing how he knew
it that the Phoenix had gone had left
Hogwarts for good just as dumore had
left the school had left the world had
left Harry credence's Phoenix leaving
casts a rather ominous Shadow over the
fate of credence and to me this
suggested his time may have been very
limited pair that with his deteriorating
health and abrupt end to his existence
in Harry Potter law and I'd be willing
to bet that Credence died fairly shortly
after his reunion with his father tragic
but likely no information has been
provided as to who credence's mother was
but my best guess is that it was a
muggle woman from godric's Hollow Tina
and N despite a budding and dare I say
unusual romance between nutes commander
and Tina Goldstein in the first two
films she is strangely and abundantly
absent from the third film this left
many fans confused as to what comes of
their relationship The Fairly
unsatisfactory answer behind Tina's
absence is that she has taken on a new
role as head of the aura department but
to me this never quite made any sense
I'm really really not sure what could
have possibly been more important than
taking down the largest imminent threat
in The Wizarding World helping the man
she loves and oh I don't know saving her
sister of course Tina does show up at
the very end of the film much to a
thrilled n making an appearance at Jacob
and queen's wedding but things are still
left awfully unclear allow me to fill
you in well you may be delighted to hear
that n and Tina do end up getting
married amidst the Romantic display put
on by Jacob and Queeny at their wedding
I suspect that Tina and new may have
finally been bitten by the Love Bug and
express their feelings for one another
witnessing those close to them in a
marital embrace it's likely that they
got married shortly thereafter following
marriage the pair eventually moved to
England dors it to be precise and end up
having one son Ralph's scander the
schander residents also housed three pet
nles hoppy Millie and mher and n and
Tina also later become
great-grandparents to twin boys Lin and
Lysander after their son Rolph marries
and has children with none other than
Luna love good what really happened with
Ariana Dumbledore how did she die it
shouldn't come as much of a surprise to
anyone that Dumbledore carried with him
an insurmountable amount of guilt for
his role in the death of his sister and
the conventional understanding of her
death was that she was caught in the
crossfire of a three-way duel between
alus abber forth and Grindelwald beyond
that nothing else is revealed regarding
Ariana's fate but I think it may have
been albus's spell that ended up killing
her right from the very beginning of the
Fantastic Beast franchise grindal
displays a strong obsession with
controlling the obscurus Credence
barebone and I think that this Obsession
stems from his past encounters with
Ariana I suspect that Ariana an
obscurial herself was able to overpower
grindewald during a fight that
ultimately led to her death in her
confusion Ariana took grindelwald's wand
possibly attempting to save Abba forth
from the cruciatus curse that grenald
was torturing him with however it was
Albus who ended up killing Ariana during
the incident which later gave him the
ability to defeat
grenald I suspect that grenald had
possession of the Elder Wand before his
encounter with Albus abber forth and
Ariana in godric's Hollow there would
have been enough time for this as Amber
for mentioned that they had known each
other for a few weeks before he was
about to return to school grindlewald
had been researching the wand during the
beginning of the summer after leaving
durmstrang and likely already had
knowledge of the Hallows before meeting
alus during the fight the allegiance of
the Elder Wand shifted to Arana first
then to Albus this explains why it took
Albus so long to confront grenald
directly he knew that doing so would
confirm that he was the one who killed
Ariana in essence alus carried the
weight of this guilt for the rest of his
life I'm not even remotely suggesting
that alus killed Ariana intentionally
but I do think that it was his spell
that killed her and I think that this
also explains the highly complicated
dynamic between Albus and abber forth
what happened to Nini after crimes of
grindal similar to Tina Nini drops off
the face of the Earth after the crimes
of grindal and this is likely due to her
irrelevance to the story as the films
progress however there was undeniably a
fair bit of character development for
Nini and I for one became invested we
also know that she eventually becomes
Voldemort's sidekick but how and when
does she make the transition from a
helpful and kind woman to an evil snake
unfortunately there is zero information
available that fills the void between
nini's last known appearance in
1927 and the 1980s when nin meets
Voldemort in the forest of Albania at
this point Nini would have likely fully
assumed her snake likee form and
Voldemort would have been hiding in his
disembodied State following his defeat
at the hands of The Potters in case you
forgot nagini suffered from a blood
malediction which meant that she was
destined to transform into a snake in
youth a maledictus can transform back
and forth at will but as they grow older
they have less and less control
resulting in an inevitable and permanent
transformation into their animal form
what their initial interaction would
have looked like is anyone's guess
however we do know a couple of things
about Voldemort that would have helped
him in interacting with a giant snake
first of all Voldemort is the descendant
of Salazar sutherin this means that his
connection to snakes is strong and that
he can communicate with them due to his
ability to speak parcel tongue I suspect
that Nini who would have been stuck in
her maledictus form for quite some time
at this point would have probably leaped
at the opportunity to finally speak with
someone she was a lost maledictus de
void of communication and finally she
encountered someone who could understand
her it was someone that she could tell
her story to whether Voldemort would
have been able to recognize that she was
a maledictus or not is unclear however
he is an extremely versed legilimens so
I'm sure he could have taken a look
inside of her mind and figured it out at
this point in time both Nini and
Voldemort were a bit lost in the world
similar to when she first met Credence
Nini was stuck in a snake form an
entirely new ident
and was completely devoid of human
interaction she probably had no idea
what her next move was going to be and
she must have been incredibly lonely in
Voldemort's case he had just been
recently defeated and was likely also at
a bit of a loss for what to do next for
these reasons I think that it is only
natural the two would pair up each of
them having something to offer the other
without Nini it would have been
considerably more difficult to return to
a corporeal form and without Voldemort
Nini would have had no purpose in the
world and no one to talk to she would
have just been alone Nini became
instrumental in Lord vort survival
before he could be restored to his real
body and her Venom was even used as an
Elixir that helped him to survive it was
one of the primary ingredients in a
potion that he used to rebuild his
strength Nini also helped Voldemort to
commit numerous murders and one murder
in particular the murder of Bera jorkins
sealed their bond more than ever you see
after the death of Bera jorkins Nini
became one of Voldemort's Haw ruxers she
was now more than just the companion of
Voldemort a fragment of Voldemort's Soul
lived inside of her by this point in
time her previous shy and gentle nature
was no more and she became a weapon for
Lord Voldemort the man to which she was
completely loyal in my view nini's path
towards villain is not all that
surprising she was born with a blood
curse and for the first few Decades of
her life she was tormented and forced to
perform by an abusive traveling circus
nagini forms a temporary alliance with
Credence in the crimes of grindlewald
coming together due to their shared
experiences as outcasts and their desire
to find belonging and acceptance despite
knowing each other for a relatively
short period of time the pair form a
strong bond however this is relatively
shortlived at grind wald's rally Nini
tries to convince Credence to stay with
her however que doesn't listen to her
and instead decides to join grinder Wald
in order to learn his true identity
devastated Nini also Witnesses Lita's
death and is just barely apparated to
safety by Yousef abandoned by the only
person that she felt she could rely on
and continuing to deteriorate from her
blood malediction it's likely that
nikini simply gave up and lost faith in
others entirely what happened to
grindlewald as grindelwald's power grew
many beli that Alber Dumbledore would be
the only one capable of stopping him
however due to a blood pact made in
their youth Dumbledore was for many
years unable to directly confront
grenald in 1927 the blood packed vial
was stolen from grindewald by Newton's
commander and when given to Dumbledore
he hoped to break the pact in 1932
Dumbledore and his brother abber forth
intervened when grindal attempted to
harm Credence barebone leading to the
breaking of said blood paack this
finally left the door open for
Dumbledore to challenge grindal in a
duel by 1945 some 13 years after secrets
of Dumbledore ended and his temporary
defeat grindal had managed to make quite
the comeback he managed to Rally support
through a combination of strategic
manipulation and persuasive rhetoric
utilizing his Charisma and captivating
speaking abilities grindlewald aimed to
appeal to the sentiments and fears of
wizards in which who were disillusioned
with the existing order he skillfully
painted a picture of a future where
Wizards would assert their dominance
over Muggles promising a world in which
the magical Community would no longer be
forced to hide or live in fear the very
same type of language that once
convinced alus Dumbledore the only
difference was that this time around
grindal didn't attempt to hide his
darker nature or more Sinister
intentions and by 1945 the public outcry
against against growald became too
strong his presence could no longer be
ignored and he could no longer be
allowed to grow his forces
unchallenged this resulted in Alber
Dumbledore The Wizarding world's Only
Hope finally confronting him in a
legendary duel ultimately winning and
obtaining the allegiance of the Elder
ones exact details of the duel are far
and few between but British pure blood
wizard alas Doge described their duel as
the greatest of all time and that no
duel ever matched it given that both
Wizards were immensely powerful I
suspect that the allegiance of the Elder
W had something to do with the outcome I
think the Dumbledore is more powerful on
paper but I suspect that the Elder Wand
may have evened the playing field we
know that grenald physically possessed
the wand but we also know that the Elder
Wand is rather
temperamental given that grindal ended
up Surviving the duel I suspect The
Dumbledore may have simply ended up
disarming him in some way gaining
allegiance of the wand and gaining an
even larger Advantage as for the
spectacle that was the duel itself I
expect it was an impressive display of
Elemental Magic both grindlewald and
Dumbledore are known for utilizing this
type of magic in dueling settings and I
suspect that they both pulled out every
spell in their Arsenal after the duel
grindal was imprisoned in nard the very
same prison that he had built for his
enemies grenald remains there for many
decades and never makes any sort of an
attempt to Escape he is later killed by
Voldemort who seeks him out in search of
questions regarding the Elder Wand
before his death he laughs in
Voldemort's face grinder Wald didn't
fear death Voldemort or anything else
and in these final moments he did show a
hint of remorse for his actions many
decades prior entirely unwilling to help
the new dark lord and his reign of
tyranny and I suspect that's where the
films would have ended there are also a
plethora of Harry Potter events that
take place in this timeline like Tom
Riddle being brought to Hogwarts for
example but for those you'll have to go
and watch my other video if you have
more questions I'd be happy to answer
them below or if they're intricate
enough or if there are enough of them in
another video until next time remember
it does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to
live